[音楽]
こんにちはこんばんとあんたの変わりまし
た久々ですかね
こママ
始め者ちょっと
[音楽]
masa です
そのなりましたっけ
というわけでやってまいりましたただいま
ですね時刻は夜中の零治13分今ですね
我々がいるのはですね神奈川県の方にい
ます今回行くところがですねこれ
ランキング見たら多分ベビーを今回伊東さ
なんですけども
某サイトによる差異共振音スポット
ランキング日本大
サインです
マジですか今回行くのですね某サイトに
よるとランキングに本体産休前版トンネル
でございます
it その神奈川県にあるしと c の間
にある飛んでみなんですけども別目准一
くん所
純一君
[音楽]
8別名准一くん
道路とも呼ばれています q 前場となり
が[ __ ]スポットになってひっかけはですね
昭和40年結構昔なんですけどマイクの
事故があってバイクがカーブを曲がりきれ
なくて対向車のトラックと正面衝突でなく
なってしまったと園生後急前場トンネル
付近にもう死んだ内で淳一
という言葉が書かれた看板はと御馳走様が
建てられたし来ての通知調べると事故で
亡くなった少年の名前が11だったんです
ね意外とねその
こういうことがあったよっていうのは
シンプルな
心霊スポットなんですけどもうこれだけ
ランキングが上にあるっていうことでば
相当
何かあるんじゃないかなという感じがし
ますただちょっと自己あったよってだけ
ですよねマート4コーナーで怪奇現象が
ですね少年の優出が車やバイクの場合で
飛び出すとがいたってシンプルだね今回
すごい昔にバイクに自分があったという
感じ
という感じでいきたいとおもいますまた
イベントもよろしくお願い致します
よろしくお願い致します
ってなんですけども
国家なんですよ混ぜて霊感あるじゃんそれ
というか今までいってねく色々あったじゃ
ないですか何とにいられますよねなんか
入り3つ車止まったりしたんです
一番しんどかったされおっしゃるかと思い
ます本当に泊まったん全然違いましたよ俺
都市ですポップいったカティア塗装とそ
すぐ連絡車で僕はもう霊能力者さんにせ
られてもらったらあなたが来ないけど
あなたの周りの人とを打つとかが危ない
から気を付けてって言われてるんで僕は
大丈夫です
なんですけどさせるにね一緒に宮所の後輩
だけにつらい思いさせてはいけないと思い
まして私もちょっとメンタルをブラシて
から行こうかなと思いまして
今から英語禁止私英語しゃべったらお酒
飲みますね何やってるんですかを先ほど部
ことによってはかなりその気持ちの部分と
いうかがまた試験といろいろ乱れる売れる
と思うのでかなり振れば僕をあの雅也に
何かがを掘るのシェアできないかなと思う
確かまあ心霊系はスア今もうはいしあって
いませんまあのしっかり審判に従って英語
しゃべったらお酒一杯飲みますいっぱい
一口じゃなくていっぱい一応あのさんしり
ませ4スト zero 特化型ってやる
全部飲んで明けたこの容器にちょっとつ
このは確かにかしていくっていう感じで
まずはポップ作り済むそうですコップ作り
始めて夜酒飲んだ後心霊スポットいっての
はコッパって
英語すよねー
エスポット摩耶子じゃね
じゃあこれ3杯分だと思うんですよ今回の
次からこれぐらいのはスト zero を
飲んできますストロングゼロはトロンだと
ゼロでに単語ですよねさあこの後にはいの
よねっ
そのしゃべらないじゃおう心にの意識だ
チェーン
あ日本車が美味しい年になったかなんか昔
場でなんかにが意味作ったかなと意外と
おいしいや絶対そんな買って競売工事
ちゃんしか見たかった
結構極道のペースですはっはっは設定
ちゃったわああ
よしっ
のいましたずっとしゃべり星だけ僕
しゃべりましたねねぇよねはいなんて言っ
てましたっけ
須藤0対それが入って体
このお酒ってなんてのほうがいいでしょ
さっきそれは強0
2予冷です2 o でいただきます馬のば
これでもいいショー
今まで喋った英語版はそうで映像ですね
大変です序盤から俺を下げ弱いからです
確かに2するあんま合わせすぎちょっと
理解に一人で
静岡はれたら早野雲泥しょんで決して
伸ばせないのでそこ安心してください服
だけが浴びるようになります珍しいよこの
感じで行く心霊スポットあ
追加で ii ますペッ
胸追加スポットですねこれスポット風呂
スポーツ
この札頑張ってる会社ちっ
入れてください
お草履
映さべらんとこ九十九屋いやいやいやいや
も務めるかもうちょっと喋った方がいい
ですね結構近くまでついてるんだよねそう
心霊場所まで
死んで場所端に場所までも結構近づいてる
んでこのちょっと会員的なあのお店で
ゆっくりしていきたいと思いますね
[音楽]
ブーバー手に入らぬ
4ねっ何やってます政権カード
最近はのみ遊戯王ドコモの怪物部だでもう
ほんとその2種類の札遊戯 of と言っ
てるけど札勇気ですまだやもう飲めないん
だねっがんばれ
ある面飲めるはいもっと話振ってよ出させ
て俺にあの海外の言葉面白いなんじゃん
ここに
ここに驚きをとこっちもありですね会いん
とこ大丈夫に帰りました今
入れて驚き男チョコ
済み分かったねぇこれ一生な館内じゃねぇ
釣行
いやいやえグリラベ4ベース
あっはぁっ
は行っ
まだ駐車場すよこれそうだよねって前の
部分の生産地と問題伸びないですね
なペースで飲んだことない
いやいいペースですね一さんありがとう
オールだめだ
鬼祭これはビックリマンチョコを受けたん
ですか
これいって魔女
驚き男をや費用がし開けます
だけれどもうああでもこれ違うじゃない
ですか
えっとこれは
英数字
接吻簿男開き
幼稚これで第一がっしりますはっはっはっ
経たよ
マーボちろさんに行きました表紙ば許し
ながらあと4 a だほぼ小松菜が多分
こだまでしれないしあってて不味かった人
だけ言うね言って馬鹿っていうのは
ヒカキンさん
えっと際魚をとバター茶もちょっとを怒ら
れそうだなぁ
はたちはダメですよ水たまり接着剤も来
られます
平均さんもダメですねできてもダメです
魔獣キーンさんもだめださあダメです先日
アンプちゃんもダメですダメですよね鉄筋
はいいやオルたら番組をだめだねまっすー
を番組もダメですかああああ菜々子ちゃん
もだめだね数番組ボンボン番組はダメが
応援する人によってさやっぱ慣れない
だろう
今二たのは当該上空気
東海上空気は割と高られないというかなー
明日もいいみたいな組織な気がするんで
描いたね組織型あなたへ文房
中では扱いやすい類であるってか最近スマ
ブラマジで暑くないですか面白いよねあと
宴桔梗第二
大元凶だよもうすごいよねそれで相克の心
からは来ましたら他の宮た
やっぱのネズミの国からですねー力ネズミ
の上に神の国の方が中路その任天堂の遠藤
は電線だわねベッジ電子機器遊戯の世界に
賛成することはなかなか無いと思ってま
すって
街が多くはちょっと感動しますねさすがに
あれ最後ですよね
俺じゃねこれ以上
u 8
先頭車は来ないねっ
行船とチケットはもうこれでさあチケット
を取ってい
何くっついたですかうんあー分
でもがもが出ましたよね入れてください
ああ
もう絵下手無理だ
さっほー総社歩が不審者無 the
year
あっ低すぎる
ああ
矢沢いい一致が仰って彫ってない
あの赤さ
伝わるかなぁこれ赤座がどうしたって
アーサーローハさず
まずい要望を貸さずどんな格好んのこれへ
へっ痛い3位名所する
台山院コスメはこちら
ポイント台打っ級ってん突発タイダイも
はいもう
はない
ここから観賞大メジャー行っ
あ
温泉いこかメンター
全部食ったんすかえっ食べたかった路面
ねー
山の子時間数だけで変革だっけそんな折り
方ですゴミっていうんですねあっはは
キャップ
ん
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇいたなさたさあ来
ました
あるホテル
よえっええっ
青銀砂たちとふと思いますだモデル人もい
ますあれはトンネルけどまんねもう
これこれ
なぜこんな近い事あるこれ
ます
を基氏近いこれもついた桜
気持ちとダメはいというわけでまあさん屋
さんにあっはっ
も出来上がっちゃいましょ発生させる外に
つきましたちょっとちょっとだけあの車
ためいる場所がないんでちょっと歩くん
ですけどしっかりと微信です求めていき
たいと思います捧げる僕はを現場つくと
オク詐欺じゃないんで
命がふざけてるんですよいつものあなたも
ね
は裂波白子やんだなただ本当にあのいつも
その強いメンタルじゃないからこの時で
しっかり後輩を守りたいと思います
裸足何が起きるのかませは結構霊感ある方
なんてかなり強いと思います
早速降りましょう
説明
バーッ春よ来い
思え最高や何の煮物
お兄ちゃんですねマッチョ
スマホとしたらって言っていってね
春効果とんと言っ
こんな感じのめちゃめちゃみなさーん
後ろパチパチ天井まず
本当だ本当なんです本当ダメですよ
あれ
masayo
良い冷めてきたおー
すごいねと池畠見える
鳥肌が止まらない異常すぎるいきましょう
か今でしょ
持っトンネルが近いです
手書きがサーブ宮フォンよなんか分かる
このナビかさ
ないっしょ
see
長いよね1本1本がすごくさあトンネルに
近づいてきましたあります
本当にを叫んだけどでは入っていき
ましょう
楽しいなこれ
ですよそういうで一番大切でしょ何か
もっちりして各おもちゃでしょこれ
[音楽]
やばいすごい寒い中驚異のせいじゃなく
普通に体調悪い頭痛い
使用しちゃったとしたん
今
なんかさんろっ
なんかたはいを感じ
前田2そうなず後ろ気になって仕方ないぞ
あっ違う
瀬奈あさみも前より都立ばたり強化くっ
すごいん
なんか利益がすごい
[音楽]
すぐ出口ですね摘んでいくとさあやっぱ
ストア春有名なな方が美味しいどっち
かっていうかこっちがはだよねだってさあ
タッツ時さ立った時さんすべき感じる心
ですから何コンサー
すごいよこっちゃんを普通にラブ方がいい
まさに戻ろうかいややっぱすごいよこの方
がこっち抜きの圧が分かる子の親はさん
じゃないん
結構さ
比較にならないぐらいさんっ
箱はよね今日してどしどしたと主張しまし
た
ちょっとだけますよね菊井と聞こえが利く
買ってこの7市の日みたいなやつですかん
んですかありえない子が聞こえためですか
車ではないネウロじゃないですよ
アンナと出ないよ環境音でい
ひやー見てるでしょ
立っややっぱこっちがは何だろうねぇ
すごいじゃんなんかん
きついも行くのか
[音楽]
お酒あんだけ飲んだ人と思えないぐらい
冷静で3問
何の音だったんでも石鹸を
ありえないコーンだったよね
記者パン買った人の本意だったのかななん
でこっちがにとなっちゃったんですけどね
飛脚です
えっ
銃声
なんか破裂した音がしたねん
すっごいこれはもう翻刻なくなって待って
本当に前 burn to にもこれとか
もさあし通算みてくれ
こんなの見たことないぞ
今なんかさー
えっ
待ってそうでしょ橋場さんの門のふもと
じゃないですかちゃうちゃうちゃうちゃう
ねうしてないからしねーから本当に言って
ないって言ってればそっちが聞こえました
よ
これじゃないよねっ
[音楽]